Downtown Amarillo perhaps best known for
being a stop on the road now though it's
the focal point of the war on abortion
rights
a judge in this small City handing down
a ruling which could profoundly affect
abortion access across America
until now the Battleground has mainly
been abortion clinics now the pill with
a Prestone which accounts for more than
half of abortions in the United States
is under attack to a judge ruling in
favor of a Conservative Christian group
who argue it's unsafe this decision
means a drug which has been legal for 23
years could be pulled from shells in
just a week's time the Justice
departments say they will appeal the
ruling but for women like Angel it
represents a worrying escalation already
a mother of three she didn't want any
more children recently terminating a
pregnancy by taking with a pristine you
can do it at home it's convenient it's
easy it's safe it's crazy that it's
being criminalized when
just a couple years ago it was fine did
you ever imagine that this country would
be in this position I would have never
thought this this war on women has been
so much more intense these last past
couple years
the judge who handed down this decision
is Matthew kasmarek appointed by Donald
Trump during his time as president
kazmeric is a devout Christian who
already has a Litany of controversial
legal rulings to his name he is one man
who has now made a decision which could
disrupt the lives of millions of women
in a state fiercely protective of the
right to bear arms some are intent on
removing a woman's right to choose God
makes a decision not us and I know that
we take it into our own hands and make
the decisions but you know so you
wouldn't agree with abortion pills I
would not do you feel like
getting rid of abortion pills is just a
continuation of the beginning stepping
stone of them slowly taking away all our
rights our bodily function rights yes
how does that make you feel angry
[Music]
the Christian group which brought this
case is the alliance defending Freedom
we want women to be informed when they
do take these drugs about the risks
associated with them is this actually
less about safety and more about
politics and moving towards a total ban
on abortion pills is that what really
you would like to see in this case is
solely focused on the health and safety
of women and girls but just minutes
after the Texas ruling a judge in
Washington state made a dramatic
intervention ordering that mythopristown
remained legal and available in some
liberal states
the stage has been set for a standoff
which will likely reach the Supreme
Court
for women in America the legal maze
which is abortion access has become even
trickier to navigate Martha Kellner Sky
News Amarillo